[Music]
your opinion of this may change or it
might stay the same but it's going to
keep my mouth shut
[Laughter]
a woman was sucked
no it's not that and bart's like
i'm sticking to this man say though
bart's opinions go back in time
as he gets older
so this is uh
this is in the uk
a guy
uh confronts a burglar in his home
and uh
stabs him to death
and the uh homeowner
is then sentenced to 19 years in jail
come on
what yeah
wait what so the burglar comes to the
guy's home and the guy stabbed him in
the home defense or self-defense and
then he
has 19 years this must be in san
francisco
burglar [ __ ] the judge like yeah
judge's son
i mean that's like some california laws
right where like if the burglar slips
and falls in your house
and then he sues you we're like
exporting our laws now but the thing is
that saves you this is weird but i think
there's insurance
that you can get for that what for that
slip of 500 well yeah and to defend
yourself i don't doubt that as insurance
you can get for anything yeah you can
get insurance yeah exactly that's what
you could ensure [ __ ] ass change like
it was like
like i softly heard that you know i
can't you know fully remember we heard
it yeah yeah i can't fully remember
where i heard he's dropping a
conversation
what's the term
what's the term when you have a like a
fund for these types of slush fund like
a slush fund
when you have money set aside for just
in case this politician wants to [ __ ]
all these hookers and make them like
hush-hush like hush money like a
band-aid yeah it's like it's usually
like taxpayer money so it's kind of nice
for the politicians yeah because it's
not their own
it's funny but it sucks so what do you
think what do you think happened here so
like well i i know like um just from
having uk friends and stuff
their
lucky idea their idea
their id
their their whole their the way that
they perceive the us right and you know
how we have the castle law and you know
how like we shoot a [ __ ] if they
come into our house whatever they think
that's ridiculous
they're they think they think it's
excessive or they think it's like it's
excessive because so what here's the
thing what's the alternative yeah
because it also comes from
maybe
the le the type of crime is different
because in the u.s right you might have
someone who's on pcp that comes breaks
into your house [ __ ] rapes your whole
family and then stabs them after and
they don't even steal [ __ ] so like
yeah you don't know the intention you
don't know if they're gonna come in and
maybe steal your [ __ ] chocolate box
and run away or they're there to like
rope up your whole family and then do
torture you don't know you don't know
you [ __ ] don't know that's why in the
states it's like if they're just coming
in you just shoot [ __ ] first you just
don't know
maybe out there it's just like oh it's
not worth a life and it's like what do
you mean it's not worth the life they're
gonna you don't know what they're gonna
do to you the best thing too is they
they judge us so hard over there they're
like man americans are [ __ ] crazy and
they're like yeah so that's why we we we
kind of react if somebody's in our
[ __ ] house
well that's a little much i think right
so like for them they're like it doesn't
make any sense if someone's just coming
into your house to steal things why
should you kill them and we're like
i don't know if they're here to steal
well that's probably not that's probably
not their culture though like our
culture
consists of like yeah crazy [ __ ]
you know like when you think about it
our states have castle a lot too like
california doesn't happen what's up
sorry what's castle law so there's
actually castle law has i think uh
three tiers
and i believe california is a third tier
but the first one is if someone steps on
their lawn you could just blast them
anyone that has uncomfortable california
that's like temperatures
yeah if it's your own property yeah
gardeners just go down daily yeah
it's a real problem actually it's a big
problem the third one is they gotta walk
up with all their equipment they
announce themselves the third the
gardener that person the trespasser has
to have have to present a lethal threat
where you literally feel like not only
where's it and it's here yeah that the
third one so where where not only do you
feel like your life is in danger your
family's life is in danger and there's
nothing else you could have done like
you can't jump out the window or do
anything like that that's number three
and the number two is like somewhere in
the middle i think it's just danger i
think it's just danger with someone
rolling up to your [ __ ] house like
that's what yeah i'm a [ __ ] that
i don't know that does not live here
like you're just gonna roll it yeah what
are you doing that's what happens with
cops nowadays in america yeah cobble
wrote your house you might die i'm gonna
uncover
certain details as we go and then tell
me if your opinion changes at all texas
is number one by the way though what do
you mean
the tears i think hawaii is even worse
than california in the sense where um
you can't really protect yourself you
have to run out of the house if you have
a chance to you gotta jump into it so
she comes in
you gotta grab your surfboard
why don't you go to kauai
when the burglar comes you have to tie
yourself up
here's some more details they just shall
help me
so the guy who's the homeowner
is a drug dealer
oh the guy who came to rob the house was
coming to steal the drugs not a customer
he had to kill him he's gonna take still
justified yeah dude i mean that happens
all the time yeah where drug dealers get
robbed because they like they're like
you're not gonna call the cops okay yeah
true my dad used to do it oh yeah this
is what he would do you could rob other
drug dealers oh [ __ ] lucrative yeah it's
good business you still don't know what
the [ __ ] they're gonna do in your house
yeah all right but like also i mean if
the guy's a drug dealer yeah he's
probably on edge yeah
it's funny that he stabbed him because
it's like
that's uk
so
how about this the robber was unarmed
how do i know that yeah that's the
that's the other thing
how do you know if they're
i'm not going to hurt you yeah did he do
that trust me i don't have nunchucks
underneath my jacket
hey why did you bring that up
did you do that is that in a statement
where is like you know he got caught
he's like or is there food he was
clearly unarmed yeah
i have no weapons he was completely
naked holding his hands in here i don't
know
just here for the drugs yeah so what do
you i mean that might be justified then
still justified so was he on uh was the
guy who came in to rob like was he just
a crackhead so no he wasn't a crackhead
so he was a he was a drug dealer himself
probably how would you try to rob
someone unarmed
like that's the weirdest okay
where the drugs are they waited for the
guy to leave and he did leave
and then uh they waited for his wife who
also lived there to like
go outside at least they were nice about
that yeah then they went when they you
know at the perceived time that uh they
felt like the guy was in there they go
in so they're burglars they're not yeah
that's there's a difference
yeah there's no
intentions like the dudes from home
alone oh
so they go in there and then uh what
happens is the guy actually comes back
and catches them here's what actually
happened okay and this is why he got to
19 years
so the guy's unarmed
the homeowner comes in and stabs the
dude multiple times the guy like runs
away
is now outside oh that's outside so in
the first initial stabbing that he
stabbed him right above his eyebrow
the blade broke off in the guy's head oh
so we got another knife still like runs
away he's outside homeowner chases him
out pins him against the car with the
broken knife continues to stab and slice
him up
to the point where the dude is just he's
just dying and that he goes out of his
way to continue just like
over
he only got 19. and what about the other
guy he just ran away well there were two
other guys that they just ran away yeah
dude i can't say i wouldn't do the same
[ __ ] honestly just in the moment being
[ __ ]
yeah so uh
because i'll be thinking about they're
gonna come back and kill me so i need to
[ __ ] kill them [ __ ] dude
that's i feel like that's yeah
irrational to be honest especially as a
drug they already know where you live
you don't know where they live they've
already been in my house gotta catch one
of them yeah please yeah so he stabs him
in the neck three times with the broken
knife outside
severs his jugular veins jesus christ
what's a jugular vein it's the one that
you can't fix yeah the main thing once
it's the one that if it's severed you're
probably gonna die like in like under
three minutes you're bleeding like under
three minutes so that dude is now on the
ground bleeding out the homeowner gets
in his car and tries to run him over
holy [ __ ] this guy's hardcore
now would you still go that far he then
misses the body imagine getting in your
car just for the interview this is the
uk so he probably has a mini cooper or
something too so he's just trying to run
him over whatever it was a fiat 500
kept rolling his ankle dude
so the guy survived a couple rolls
oh he gets in the car tries to run him
over misses and hits a garden wall like
he hits some other thing and the brick
fell off and hit him in there
oh man
yeah so the judge because of all these
details was like
that's just way too much yeah that was
too much assault
on his end yeah well that kind of thing
here like that's yeah right here right
yeah yeah right that's life here
yeah there that's right yeah over there
they're like they could write a book on
vengeance for that one yeah yeah that
crazy thing is that the reason why uh he
even noticed the burglars was because he
had a ring cam
so see dude
yeah
but that's where the judge goes hey you
saw in the ring cam that they were
already there you could just like expose
that they're caught and they can't
continue the burglary but instead he
turned into [ __ ] jason voorhees right
so he wouldn't want to expose that their
cop because that would be like calling
the cops that's what complicates the
entire situation is because he's a
[ __ ] drug dealer and they already
know that he's a drug dealer your honor
i can't be looking like a [ __ ]
what else they gonna [ __ ] keep
disrespecting me and then the judge is
like our word
yeah you're right you're right yeah the
ollie g comes out like if i do this
nobody on the street is gonna rot me
again that's true
my house got robbed before
and uh
and i saw them and i went to go get my
gun and they all hop the fence and stuff
like that and then when the cops came i
was just trying to like really
understand what what the law would be
and um they said that if like i got corn
because there's four dudes if i got
cornered by all four
and i
felt like my life was in danger
i could probably shoot and get away with
it but the problem is if the minute i
pull out a gun
and all four of them get scared and turn
their backs on me
and then if i shoot in the back yes then
i'm
deep deep deep [ __ ] really
but aren't you already in danger by
people you should rob people
dude yeah but that's why it's so [ __ ]
hard i should rob people like this yeah
like that's that's a tough one because
like you're already in danger with
[ __ ] four random people yeah in your
house
who's making these [ __ ] laws man
everyone gets a second best friend
you gotta have anything what i'm saying
yeah i got you give me all your [ __ ]
money
so that's the tough part with like the
tier one castle law states it's like you
gotta play this like
yeah like you know or if like let's say
some dude's on top of you right outside
of a gun
you have a knife some juice on here let
me let me show the dentist okay so like
knife right and this guy's a really good
rob and somehow if i stab him here
that's cool my life is in danger homie
just trying to [ __ ]
but then if i'm on top of him like this
and he stabbed me in here no no the
other one would be if i looked like i
pushed you off get on the floor i pushed
y'all i'm gonna get off you can't see
the phone and then i come like this now
it's a song on my end oh what the [ __ ]
so that's like imagine two dudes like a
robber and a guy defending himself but
they're both very versed in the law
so they're constantly trying to oh no no
no no no no
illegal illegal
we need a referee it looks like [ __ ]
robbing with the stars and [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you